as we continue to celebrate Hispanic
Heritage Month we are shining a light on
one Community member who is standing out
within her industry oralia jacobo began
her career at a popular fast food chain
and now she is paying it forward by
motivating others to do the same
[Music]
it is tough but I'm so proud to be a
Mexican for more than 15 years orale
jacobo has been part of the McDonald's
family in Las Vegas there's 163 please
the Acapulco native says she took a
chance on herself when she first came to
the U.S and followed the one thing she
loved him brought me to McDonald's why
because that was my favorite sandwich in
the place jacobo applied to the company
and was hired for what she says was one
of the hardest positions she's ever had
they pushed me in this spot right away
in the drive-through when I don't know
nothing about McDonald's
and I know I know I don't feel like it
was a challenge and I light challenge
over the years that challenge allowed
her to move up within the company and
recognized for her work hakubo receiving
McDonald's Ray Kroc award in 2020 which
is awarded to the top one percent of
restaurant managers worldwide for their
actions behaviors and Superior business
results she says her biggest achievement
is her team inside the Rancho and
Cheyenne operations
every time when I say no I can do it for
something she's like uh
come on don't put the stop for anything
you can do it for more today this
community leader is sharing her story in
hopes to inspire other Latinos to never
give up and be proud of who they are I'm
very proud to say I'm Mexican this is
Buddy Buddy proud to be Hispanic
well huckleball stressed how diversity
is crucial in the workplace since Las
Vegas is really a Melting Pot of culture
she also says that the Egg McMuffin
sandwich is what also keeps her smiling
throughout the years